[Music]
somewhere
[Applause]
are you ready kids
i can't hear you
[Music]
oh
who lives in a swamp right under the sea
be sure not to tell your dad what i did
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this fall
sick cities
[Applause]
if you'd like it you should have put a
ring pop on you know what i'm saying
you think genghis khan would stand for
this [ __ ]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's called a quick sip because uh i
don't really feel like doing it right
now i'm squeezing yeah i know i i know
their yakuza i'm squeezing a stress ball
today
it's actually great little stress balls
from uh uh iron mind the green look
you'll hear it
here heavy wow
[Laughter]
all right we'll try and start with
levity because it is a dark day it's a
dark day in american history and if we
can make today fun for you if we can
make the day entertaining well then
i guess we're not the failures that our
parents thought we were um a lot of
stuff going on first off the navy now
good uh good to see they have emphasis
on priorities obviously uh they are
going to start using the proper pronouns
because that was a problem really and uh
a gun control bill just passed the
senate um we're going to give you the
names of the republicans
or uh the spineless uh spot this can i
spineless weasels weasels technically
have spun spineless worms
yeah all worms are spineless that's
redundant and uh down
why things that sound good on their
surface why they hurt you and i don't
mean in a figurative sense i mean in a
very real literal sense could cause you
grave physical harm not to mention strip
you for constitutional rights and that's
sort of the theme today because we now
also see what happens when good guys
with guns meaning law-abiding citizens
cannot protect themselves when they are
not allowed their god-given rights we
have a new valdez update with the police
who lied
about a lot
when people say bush lied people died
how about these police lied and children
died and uh look
there's no other way to put it it's
cowardice it's cowardice we have a
cowardice problem in this country we
have a cowardice problem with
republicans and the gun control bill we
have a cowardice problem with police and
even if some police wanted to go in
there into the unlocked door where they
had
ballistic shields by the way and we'll
get to all these details even if they
wanted to they were too afraid to stand
up to their boss
they're too afraid to stand up to police
unions which is something that people
don't want to mention sure i backed the
blue in many ways but you don't pack all
of the blue
you know maybe there's some racist cops
out there too maybe there are maybe the
unions help cover it up sometimes
sometimes that happens absolutely it's
not the epidemic that make you believe
but it's also not exclusive to race
police lie to protect themselves just
like everyone lies to protect their jobs
the problem is when you're dealing with
municipal employee unions
who are funded by your tax dollars and
there's nothing you can do about it and
it's a pretty tough pill to swallow when
um your kids are dying behind doors in a
school
and they even stop a dad trying to save
his dying wife that's another story that
just came out by the way dad good guy
with a gun wanted to go in and protect
those kids wanted to go in and save his
wife wasn't allowed to do it but hey you
know what the good news is we have a
bunch of republicans and democrats who
will sign a bill into law that allow
more of that to happen
also mammals there are some mammals that
we have some research thomas finnegan uh
they're able to breathe anally
really
well that's a little palette cleanser
yeah i wouldn't that's probably not a
mouth to mouth yes
that's a poor choice of words on my part
i agree
so before i get to this what kind of
punishment do you think that the coward
police officers in uvalde
should face
there needs to be punishment
we're going to be talking about
cowardice and punishment unfortunately
we often think of cowardice as something
to be dismissed as something to just be
sort of pitied no it warrants punishment
cowardice leads to
death often not the death of the coward
that's the problem
it's usually the coward who causes the
death of other people
and we see that directly today so uh hey
by the way uh i know right now it's
tough to tough to buy but um
the tour rebels of the cause we are in
uh city seeing the light of crowd.com
tours in the fall we are in phoenix ahoy
houston ahoy charleston west virginia
nashville ahoy just added a second show
at 9 30 p.m in nashville because the uh
the first one uh is not quite sold out
but there aren't a lot of like tickets
with four people so if you kind of
singles left they're not
red bank new jersey
and baltimore
okay
[Laughter]
so
the good thing is here um before we get
to what's going on with the gun control
bill and and our children dying as a
result of
uh
cowardice and by the way just forbidding
people they're fundamental what is a gun
let's ask that what is a gun it's the
right to defend yourself in the year
2022. it's not just fisticuffs it's not
blades if you do not have the right to
own a firearm you do not have the right
your god you are being stripped of your
god-given right to defend yourself and
your family
that's what a gun means
but the good thing is we have an
emphasis on priorities here in this
country uh speaking of guns the navy
perfect because it's about to get really
gay yep
it turns out they were right you can
bang a guy named steve in the navy
ask him his pronouns first
boy did they they really carved
themselves out of niche the village
people and it happened before major gay
awareness was there so it happened under
straight americans eyes like liberace
there's like oh yeah it's just a bunch
of guys and chaps yeah we were all
singing the song it's just so easy to
sing right oh yeah they had like a
construction worker a leather man i like
how there's just a leather man yeah
everything else makes sense and then
leatherman leatherman there was one big
ad for leatherman tools yeah there was
also a gerber
um
it's just a leather what is his
profession that's what i mean there's
just a lot it's like okay i see your
native american i see your that's also
not a profession no but at least at
least it's a thing
actually you are paid to be native
american so technically that's a
profession but yeah when you're a
leather man you're just into deviance in
dirty parts of san francisco in the
1970s what's your job i'm just here to
be titillating yeah the original costume
had a ball gag they thought that was a
little much they pulled that off cop
construction worker profession and an
entire race of people native american
let's do that
yeah watch can't stop the music the
village people movie and i guarantee you
by the end you'll have a lower t-cell
count
something stops that music
watch it you need chemo yeah
all right so uh the navy has now taken
on uh all of these uh well they've taken
on challenges historically you know
okinawa
midway midway movie was not very good
not at all
but it was it was made
now um the navy has a new battlefield
and uh not like the air force with
stretchy maternity
suits god
they have a new training video he can't
wait for us to die
it's gonna be maverick goose is just a
just a lady with in a third trimester
crying out
oh this is a good idea that's how goose
died they weren't using his pronouns
talking to him yeah no the g-forces that
give birth to soup yeah
there's no
no goose here i believe there's a first
term you're after supposed to use and
he's dead yep
talk to me z now there's a new training
video designed to create safe spaces in
our navy using what is most important in
the field of battle uh appropriate
pronouns
hi my name is johnny and i use he him
pronouns hi and i'm kanji and i use chi
her pronouns and we're here to talk
about pronouns
what is a pronoun a pronoun is how we
identify ourselves apart from our name
and it's also how people refer to us in
conversations using the right pronouns
is a really simple way to affirm
someone's identity it is a signal of
acceptance and respect if it's a signal
of acceptance and respect how do we go
about creating a safe space for
everybody
that's a good question a really good way
to do that there is no
language instead of saying something
like hey guys you can say hey everyone
or hey team we're making sure america
isn't a safe space way that we could
show that we're allies and that we
accept
everybody is to maybe include our
pronouns in our emails or like we just
did introduce ourselves using our
pronouns
oh my gosh fantastic work guys great
great job team
did anyone know was uh where it was was
omaha beach was it a safe space
because sir how safe was that how dare
you call me
kick
pile you look good yeah looking good
i i don't can't even refer to your rifle
as she no
[Laughter]
plane names are gone all that fun why
why well here the good news is that
right now you know we're one step ahead
of the game china is commissioning new
aircraft carriers sending massive uh
i mean they're heading towards taiwan uh
russia is essentially threatening to
blow up lithuania uh so they're
strengthening their military and if you
see the recruiting ads it's very very
different but uh the good thing is we
take a softer style approach um and uh
as a matter of fact so soft that the the
united states military and uh these uh
the russian chinese chinese military
they've they've come together to form a
joint military recruitment video um here
you go
but what would i do if i
uh misgender someone
some people may be going through the
process of discovery and they are not
ready yet to tell you what their
pronouns are and that's okay
[Music]
[Applause]
so i should just lead with my pronouns
and they may follow or not and if they
don't then i can just continue to use
gender-neutral language
[Music]
the argument was if you look like a
female then it's chi her because that's
what's normal and if you make me call
you something else then you're
infringing on my rights
[Music]
but
some names are very difficult to
pronounce but do you know what is very
easy to pronounce
she he they
thank you uh bangladeshi sammy davis
junior listen
great actor
find the most effeminate just call him
just call him babe mr z jankos so
oh my gosh
um in worn out [ __ ] by the way you
know what whenever you see in those
videos they say that's a good question
it means that it's not
very much so no it means it's not a good
question that they have to reinforce
that's a good question it means that's a
really stupid question i can't believe
that you would ask also just and if
someone looks like a woman yeah because
that's how we describe all trans people
yeah what if they don't like every trans
person have ever seen in real life with
the exception of blair white what about
that what if they don't look like a
woman and they still demand to be called
a woman
what are the rules on that sammy
what if they look like both you make
them the gym teacher and you call them
coach until you figure it out right or a
disney executive producer correct can we
just say shipmate and be done with it
this would have been very easy to solve
okay if you want to solve this can't say
mate because that suggests reproductive
biological processes not at all doesn't
this has this really has to stop right
uh when we all die yeah yeah
when skynet falls judgment day is just
going to be a guy in a dress with
lipstick on the fence
have a new carrier ss penis just
pronouns mean it means you're not there
yeah right
you would think so well that's what
they're for also it would be very
confusing in battle where it's like
are we getting reinforcements like yes
they're coming over the hill sir and
that just means one trans person with a
yeah
with a handgun i said wait you said they
yeah
they is here
day's here to save you what what what
are you not getting here why is that a
weird sentence did you not watch our
stupid ass video yes
this is supposed to be a safe space uh
all right well uh your friend's dead now
yeah
i understand that but yeah we're all
bleeding yeah
what would you like me to call you as
you bleed out because men can free bleed
too oh my god okay how about you can we
just have a friendly fire incident right
now can you just frag out
i told you i could get my period that's
a chest wound yes
that is nowhere near where china would
be happy
tell my wife slash husband i love z
give me more morphine
they died
[Laughter]
remember
we should just remake private right
someone's gonna write it down come on
guys zee's come on zees
this is too much
it's too much how hard is that to just
call somebody she he him her hi him
caesar zimzam yeah when are we gonna get
to uh basic weapons training oh that's
not a thing anymore no we don't do that
no we don't do that that's aggressive
well you do not do that that's toxic
masculinity yeah when we go into china
we just start misgendering them yes
that'll take them out bring them to
their knees
and it's it takes a long time to
misgender them because it's hard to tell
them apart well they said some names are
hard to pronounce and i was like well
that's perfect
all right let's get to the
i think we've done our part here because
now we have to get to the gun control
bill a new valdez
uh okay
you thank you these republic you can
just comment you think these republicans
should be voted out
i think you know where i line up
and what is it that you've heard about
this uh this this bill exactly we've
spent some time with it this morning you
know i just have some questions on it so
let's first um
brief you for those of you who don't
know
tuesday june 21st a day which will live
in infamy the safer communities act uh
passed a
simple majority vote and it's going to
proceed in the senate the bipartisan
safer communities act came out just
about an hour before we came on the air
tonight now according to a statement the
bill quote will not infringe on any
law-abiding americans second amendment
rights unquote because there's criminal
state funding to implement so-called red
flag laws it also includes enhanced
background checks for people 18 to 21.
it addresses the so-called boyfriend
loophole with that nexus between
domestic violence and gun violence and
it also closes a number of legal
loopholes that have to do with buying
guns in criminal proceedings
okay we'll go back to clip f in a little
bit i love how he mentions boyfriend
loophole hmm now the bill doesn't say
that to be fair but the media wants to
just drill it into you boy hey how about
crazy stalker [ __ ] loophole how about
that how about amber heard loophole by
the way women commit domestic abuse at
far higher rates than men but they want
to say boyfriend loophole right domestic
abuser man loophole so let me first just
give you
uh
a briefer and then some questions i
think you all need to ask so at least 14
republicans are expected to help pass
this bill let me give you the names
mitch mcconnell in kentucky gone lindsey
graham south carolina gone john cornyn
texas gone tom tillis north carolina
gone susan collins of course should be
maine gone lisa murkowski alaska gone
bill cassidy louisiana good name but
gone roy blunt missouri gone richard
burr north carolina gone rob portman
ohio gone shelly capito west virginia
gone joni ernst of course iowa gone todd
young indiana gone and mitt romney utah
it's a marvel that he has not been gone
yet utah get your crap together
she was right so
here's what we're looking at in the bill
all references are available at
loudearthcrowder.com okay um
provides grants for state crisis
intervention programs that's a nice way
of saying red flag laws you're familiar
with those who've gone over them
individuals targeted under the
provisions have a right to defense but
they have to pay for it must be nice
um they say that there have to be
penalties for abusing the system but
guess what it goes to the states and any
state can define it
domestic violence they have a new what
they call the serious partnership
is what i believe the loophole serious
partner loophole the media says it is a
boyfriend loophole
so what does this mean because it used
to be for husbands wives uh the term
dating relationship means a relationship
between individuals who have or have
recently had a continuing serious
relationship of romantic or intimate
nature well that's very clear that can't
be abused not at all
[Music]
and uh background checks for those under
21
it's already a thing
uh but now it's double now it's double
doubly they're going to uh tighten the
regulations for trafficking weapons
performing straw purchases and by the
way it includes many many many many many
many many many many many billions of
dollars
in uh unnecessary spending okay so let
me go through this a little bit
it sounds good on its surface red flag
laws people say well well yeah we can
all be on board run flag laws people
people who are uh mentally unstable
people who are yeah mental health okay
good that's just sort of that's sort of
used as a cudgel yeah mental mental
health okay
let me cycle through a few i have a
question
all right
question
what exactly constitutes a red flag
let's be clear about that is that
clearly defined keep in mind this goes
back to the state so what is the red
flag law who determines
who is mentally unfit
does this bill make it very clear hey
this is what a red flag is there has to
be something you have to be mentioned
for example right now we have a clear
uh we have a clear hurdle that needs to
be cleared you know you have to be uh
adjudicated mentally defective yeah in a
court that's good well now red flag is
anyone can flag you your neighbors okay
all right so your neighbors can flag you
and uh that almost seems like it could
be uh you know just
ripe for abuse
what are the punishments
for someone who also uses red flag laws
is that clearly outlined in the bill no
oh wait a second the bill just says
there must be punishments but you know
it goes to the states
so
new york maybe for example they can
violate they can remove your
constitutional right to carry a firearm
to defend yourself
because some i don't know some scorned
lover someone you had a one night stand
with is mad at you
you lose your right to defend yourself
and then it's whoopsies what new york
may implement to a fine
i would be on board maybe look let's
have a compromise there needs to be a
give and take what's the give we know
what you take you take guns you take
rights red flag laws what's the give
someone abuses it ten years in a federal
penitentiary
can we do that
quit very clear
punishments for abusive red flag laws
because if you don't
this is a violation of your fundamental
rights yeah and just to be clear we are
not opposed to states being able to make
their own rules in certain situations
but the states are going to be making
rules on a law that shouldn't exist
right this law should not exist
nationally for these very reasons also
states shouldn't be making rules that
contradict
the second amendment right like it
shouldn't be there in the first place
i'm generally a federalist this is one
of the few areas it's not a state issue
yeah no it's not a state issue because
this is not some random law that was
passed by congress 15 years ago and
upheld by the supreme court erroneously
this is something in our founding
documents that we've said is important
to us existing as a country right we can
be another country if we want to have a
different law different group of
amendments that's fine but we're not
that country yeah for example they try
and say oh infringing on your rights by
using the wrong pronouns
yes on a carrier can you okay how dare
you what about infringing upon your
rights if you are living in a violent
area of town and i don't know new york
or los angeles i'm just picking them
randomly where they have in cret or
chicago or they have incredibly strict
gun laws is that not an infringement of
your rights your ability to defend
yourself hey by the way weren't we i
know they're not convenient today uh
they're not really not a valuable tool a
valuable pawn free remember the stop the
asian hate stop the asian hate seems to
me that maybe in a place like california
where these blue states will obviously
enact incredibly restrictive uh gun laws
uh might make it harder for them to
defend themselves they might have a word
or two about that yeah
there's no audio on this
oh oh oh wow it sucked what happened to
the wrong pronoun yeah that's what i
think yeah
it is ma'am goodness
so then they also say there's the uh
serious relationship loophole
serious partner loophole sorry play clip
f again this is where they say boyfriend
loophole in the media it addresses the
so-called boyfriend loophole with
yes you so called it that
[Laughter]
is it just boys though
yeah in the washington post they said it
well the with all the new sexy pronouns
it's just the boys yeah it's just the
boyfriend of all
doesn't make sense yeah
loopholes are for the boys yes so hey i
have a question
question for you
um
what are we talking about here what is
this loophole now i understand domestic
violence meaning if someone is an actual
serial abuser you know statistically
more likely to be a woman statistically
even more likely to be a lesbian woman
uh all uh references available at
lightersquare.com and you can also go to
batteredlesbians.org and give generously
we've set that up um
my question is what constitutes we know
right now that it already exists if
you're convicted
right now if you're convicted of
domestic abuse
right you can't own a firearm if you
domestically abuse your wife or
domestically abuse your husband so what
is this well this expands it
it expands it allows the states to
expand it to any degree that they want
where it just can be a serious partner
which can really just mean anyone you've
dated
and by the way
it's really easy you don't have to be
convicted
someone can just get a restraining order
by going before a judge and saying hey
he hit me and abused that system and you
lose your right to defend yourself but
we've never seen that mattress girl
we've never seen that uva we've never
seen that duke lacrosse we've never seen
that amber herd that's a very real
scenario where let's say if they lived
stateside as opposed to their castle
their chateau in france where johnny
depp
could have had his right
to own firearms removed because of
something that we know is false remember
heard it's a very real scenario and by
the way it happens all the time comment
below if you're one of those guys or if
you're one of those women usually
happens to guys
well the process to get it back
is painful well the process to get it
back if you're convicted is very long
but that's that yeah but even yeah yeah
yeah but even if you're promised
yeah this is one of those things you're
guilty until proven innocent almost like
somebody can go and make an allegation
against you and then you can have your
gun rights taken away and then you have
to go and prove
that no wait a minute that that's that's
wrong i never did any of this i never
said any of that by the way we only
dated we only went out twice right it
was not a serious relationship you know
it's so subjective now and they actually
said in the bill they were having a
really hard time defining this or in the
article about the bill they were having
a really hard time defining this and
they couldn't come up with a good way to
do it so instead of actually doing their
jobs and figuring out a way to define
this to make sure that it wasn't put
onto the states
they just said we have no idea we'll let
them decide yeah by the way do you ever
just wonder when you look at these you
go wait hundreds of billions of dollars
to just say hey state uh do that put my
name on that you're like well how does
that cost hundreds of billions of
dollars you just wrote a sheet of paper
well there's paperwork and then you have
to you're not doing anything there's a
file there's a filer i mean there's
usually when i file something it is
around half a bill yeah well you know
this is a good law where it's just like
uh elected a firearm have you been in a
relationship with someone yes
please get out of my store you know you
know what something we're not talking
about either we've gone through this and
now people have had a chance to dissect
it and kind of understand what it says
senators that voted on this
got this bill two hours before the vote
you guys gonna say that somebody made a
snarky remark to like a fifth grader
could have read it in about an hour and
i'm like it's not about reading a bill
it's about comprehending the bill and
understanding the unintended
consequences in the bill fact checking
the bill to make sure these things are
true and then also all the stuff in the
bill that doesn't have anything to do
with gun control at all by the way name
one of these provisions in here that
potentially could have stopped the
shooting and remember before you say he
was 18 year old and had a rifle he also
had handguns he could have gone into
that building with handguns as well
right that would have happened he had
them shouldn't have had them that was
illegal that was already illegal
tell me what would have stopped this
what are you doing this is the police
we'd like to think so yeah but no no
well no no that didn't work ballistic
shields no no no we'll get to that oh
boy yeah those things are you know you
can't have that an armed guard so it
sounds good what constitutes domestic
abuse hey look women
let me paint let me put you in this
picture because let's be honest
statistically women are more likely to
be domestic abusers but women are far
more likely to follow restraining orders
and abuse a system to accuse someone of
being a domestic abuser that is a fact
okay reference is available at a lot of
credit.com but let's say you're a woman
who is now dating a guy
or is married to a man
who has a crazy ex-girlfriend this is an
unrealistic scenario i know women you've
never had to deal with the crazy ex of
your boyfriend
who is falsely accusing him of abuse and
now your man can't have a gun in your
house to protect you and your kids do
you see the problem do you see the
unintended consequences look you start
with constitutional rights
period you have the right to own a
firearm
and then if people violate other
people's constitutional rights through
force if people violate the law not law
new laws that you create but
constitutional laws that's the only way
that someone would forfeit any right to
a firearm by the way i love how they say
this would not affect law-abiding
citizens at all well guess what you were
a law-abiding citizen yesterday in rhode
island no you're not no whoops it goes
into effect your life first but my point
is this ten round magazines yeah now
illegal you were legal
you were a law abiding citizen but now
you're not you can own a gun but we've
neutered it right essentially so i hope
you took really good training middle of
the night shooting this is at the same
time i believe it's is it new york or
california where they're not allowing
police to pursue yeah criminals on foot
that just came out i think it was
chicago was it chicago or l.a uh we'll
have to find it we'll have to find it
it's one of those because it's like oh
because the last couple of times we've
chased people that pulled guns on us we
shot and defended ourselves right and we
don't that just looks bad so we want
them to you know just run off into your
neighborhood where of course you're not
allowed to have firearms well what we've
looked at is uh san francisco and it
looks like that all those free you know
lootings they look good and here's
another one where people they say straw
purchases and this has often been used
interchangeably with the gun show
loophole here's my question
what does this bill actually do how does
it change the laws of straw
purchases what is a straw purchase
now let me be clear about this this is
one thing that really confused me i
tried to spend time with the bill this
morning and i couldn't make sense of it
and let me explain to you why it doesn't
make sense yeah
so here's what it is a straw purchase uh
and uh for example i've i've done this
where i've had uh like classic firearms
or something like that and i've
transferred them i've had uh my half
asian lawyer do a bill of transfer to
family members things like that this is
something that happens okay that's legal
to do people try and act so that's a gun
show loophole where you simply go to a
gun show or you go online and just a
bunch of people are transferring you
firearms right now
it is already illegal just to be clear
for example let's say i had an old
single action revolver like an old navy
revolver and transferred it to my dad as
a gift okay
it would already be illegal for me to do
that
if he cannot legally own a firearm
meaning if he's a felon right
we'd both be on the hook it's already
illegal
this is just go so this doesn't make the
transfer what people consider the gun
show loophole it doesn't even make that
illegal it just makes it more illegaler
if i
transfer privately
to a criminal relative or friend it's
double secret illegal exactly
it all makes sense
and it adds by the way it adds
exportation oh so in other words it's
now extra illegal for you to uh transfer
off the books
guns to the mexican drug cartel that
needed to be because because they're
having a problem
what am i going to do with all my
records
i don't know man
no one's left unscathed in this one yeah
i have all my book
what's the point of being a bookkeeper
so it's just balancing you don't have
evidence making it more illegal or more
illegal or any because people think oh
red flag laws that's very clearly
defined no it's not oh wait the domestic
abuser law i can't believe we didn't
have them in the books we already do
they're just a clear-cut legal
definition oh wait a second they're
going to close the loophole where he
can't do private transfers you can
they're just going to make it illegal to
give it to criminals which was already
illegal anyway and by the way none of
this is at a federal level it kicks it
to the states
right hmm and this is the thing this is
the thing here okay this is not a state
issue and i'm someone who believes that
the states are great great little
science labs where you can change fine
you guys want to legalize hallucinogen
mushrooms great
texas can say that they don't want to do
that
you guys want to have a different
property tax fine you guys want to have
a different school system you guys want
to allow school vouchers great states
have the right to do these things states
do not have the right for example to
tell you that you can't speak out
against the government states do not
have the right to tell you that your
first amendment no longer applies they
can't do that because it is one of your
fundamental human rights what does that
mean people will say oh rights are just
rights are just an illusion the idea of
god-given rights well look even if you
think that that's still how we recognize
them here in this country and it's a
very different form of recognition than
in other countries that's why we're the
only one with the first amendment and
we're the only country with the second
amendment to protect it this is not a
state issue so the shitty little
libertarians who are in a in an
internship at a think tank who said uh a
state thing it's not this is not what
i'm not saying all libertarians but i'm
saying there are some who've made that
argument this goes to the states
none of this should go to the states and
let me be really clear about something
too
something that's really been bothering
me lately is the the false
pseudo-intellectual platitudes that you
hear people say oh freedom's just an
illusion you know what that may be but
you know what's a greater illusion the
idea of security here in this country
the idea that you're going to protect
people by removing guns hey the idea of
secure security you believe the tsa can
actually stop a terrorist attack you
have any idea how easy it would be
do you you think the fbi
keeping you safe
security here in the united states which
is the constant it's the constant cloud
of security threats that allows this
government
to violate you of your fundamental
rights it really is an illusion you can
comment below does anybody really
believe that this government can keep us
safe
keep us safe both from external threats
with the military that uses the proper
pronouns and by proper having improper
pronouns and from internal threats like
i don't know school shooters who leave
doors unlocked and police are too big of
a pu they're too big of a of a troop of
[ __ ] to do anything but you really
think that security is real so look if
you want to say that freedom is an
illusion and you hear this and i was
taught this in college
okay but you know what
if the government says that i'm free
from their shackles i'm not enslaved to
the government at least that allows me
the illusion of being enslaved to god
enslaved to my family my life so if it's
an illusion at least at least it's an
illusion with some degree of choice we
have no choice
over whether the government efficiently
does their job to prevent me from being
gunned down or not
freedom's an illusion no security safety
is an illusion that's why you can't
enforce it
yeah
well they've never been able to do that
they've never been able to do it and our
founding fathers knew it and that's why
they said you have to have the right to
do this and also to make sure that these
guys don't get too big of a head and
think they can just tell you to do
whatever they want which is what they're
doing right now right and a lot of
republicans if you're out there and
you're a conservative and you're saying
that this is
some a step needs to be taken there's a
reason that there's been a log jam with
gun bills because the last one didn't
really do anything even though they'll
tell you that it did we have stats to
prove that it didn't and if you're going
to start to try to make a difference
with guns in america start with
criminals
all you're doing is taking guns out of
law-abiding citizens hands or at least
people that you can just throw under the
bus and say because of a red flag we're
going to make sure you don't have a gun
it does nothing well look that no fly
list worked like a charm just ask
stephen hayes the political commentator
whose name i guess sounded exactly like
well-known sharia
law enthusiast stephen hayes you know
when you go through tsa laguardia
there's a never forget thing with 9 11
and it's like you know that was a bad
day for you right i don't know why
you're hanging that up like remember
remember when we failed at our job which
is why we have jobs now let this guy go
through i got on a plane accidentally
with wire clippers and a bottle of
ballistol yeah i had a knife on it
that's a combustible gun cleaner
the guy having a tsa the guy saw the the
guy saw the wire clippers he was like oh
yeah big nail clippers in it i was like
you just gotta put that back
first he's making fun of you in a second
what the big nail clippers i think he
was touched i had an underwear bomb it
did not function properly
guy next to me beat the crap yes that's
how they do it in detroit hey by the way
if you're watching i have no idea if
this is still on youtube right now this
is a live show monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern you can watch on mug club
you can watch on rumble if we are not on
youtube and we do not let you know go
watch it on mug club and we have an
extended show here today of course an
hour most days on mug club today's show
might go a little bit late
uh all right
let me bring you to this
so
i'm trying to think of how to
there's no good way to approach this no
there's no good way to approach this but
it does this does tie into the idea of a
gun control and i'm just going to say
this any republican not just i'm not
just talking about a vote any republican
any conservative commentator i have a
rule you know this where you don't no
friendly fire yeah i typically try and
avoid criticizing people who i think are
mostly conservative even though i
disagree with them on issues
anyone who supports this
you will be in our crosses figuratively
of course
it's going to be ugly
just so you know it's about time now
that and i'm a cultural guy going to use
this platform to make sure don't care
who you are don't care if you've been on
the show don't care if you're a friend
if you're on board with these red flag
laws if you aren't bored with what is in
this bill
if you even so much as elude or infer
anything other than total opposition
we're going to make sure that every
single person watching listening knows
your name i just want to be clear the
game has changed
here's why tuesday there was a testimony
on the uvalde shooting uh and this was a
colonel i think steve mcgraw the texas
director of public safety
and
there's a story of a man in valdez uh
when people say oh good guy with a gun
yeah
a man whose wife was a teacher uh was
dying
he tried to get in and save her and uh
he was actually detained and disarmed
by the police who were busy not doing
their job here's a clip we got an
officer officer ruiz whose wife called
him
and said she was she was been shot and
she's dying so certainly those things
and what happened to him was he tried to
move forward into the hallway his he was
he was detained and they took his gun
away from him and escorted him off the
scene
yeah not a just random good guy an
officer
was detained trying to go and save his
wife who can you imagine getting
weapons yeah can you imagine getting a
phone call from your spouse or from
somebody that you love dearly if you
don't have a spouse hey i've been shot
and i'm dying
i know you're probably 50 feet away in
the hallway this is what turns
law-abiding citizen no law-abiding
citizen well guess what and i'm just
gonna if that man
let's just be honest here because people
try and say i'm an extremist with this
comment and i want everyone in this room
right now to answer honestly because i'm
gonna step on a limb if you're that man
and your wife is calling you or your
child is calling you saying i am dying
and you are on the other side of that
door and you have a gun and someone is
trying to detain you
would you hesitate to shoot that person
out of the way would anyone here
hesitate i'd wing them get them out of
the way whatever i have to do to get in
there yeah because they just turned you
into a criminal they just turned you
into a criminal by trying to save your
wife's life or at least be able to speak
some last words to her
i'm not saying you should go around
shooting cops at all what i'm saying is
that guy who was an officer
was now forced to decide between last
words with his wife the love of his life
or
ah become a criminal
you shouldn't have to make that choice
that's why we have the second amendment
his wife was one of the fourth grade
teachers she was one of the two teachers
who was killed so this brings us to you
don't have you do not have
a corner on outrage left
right and this is a claim that they'll
often make but make after these
shootings well you know you just hear
these stupid people the nra the idea of
a good guy with a gun stops a bad guy
with a gun that's just a fantasy a myth
you're not trained
okay well let's go through a few
examples in the last three days but
first today in the new york times
between 2000 and 2021
mass shootings were stopped 22 times
by a bystander shooting the attacker 22
times and that's in a place guess boom
we were talking about a lot of places
like new york where people don't own
guns
that's where a lot of these mass
shootings take place
and that number would be higher if more
people were carrying firearms
not to mention the two to three million
defensive uses of firearms each year
compared to
tens of thousands of homicides mostly
gang related
and uh to here
here right now to to shut this down
forever i just had and kevin here
researcher did some
really fantastic work because we've gone
through how many examples there are of
good guys with a gun but uh these are
just a few examples here within the last
week or so defensive uses particularly
women
here's uh yesterday
a woman in a naka dish if i'm
pronouncing this correctly nakadish
louisiana shot a man invading her
bedroom
my guess is he wasn't uh my guess is he
wasn't selling girl scout cookies not a
serious partner
yesterday
former lover part-time lover
[Laughter]
uh yesterday clearwater florida a woman
shot a man entering her bedroom again
i'm noticing a trend here
hey what about rape culture stop right
culture oh here's a good way
here's a good way and it's not through
believe all women that lends itself to
stupid laws like the boyfriend loophole
law how about the
allow how it instead of hashtag believe
all women hashtag allow all women to
defend themselves
how about that novel idea june 19th
phoenix arizona um
a woman was being assaulted by her
boyfriend
shot
shot him
or shot at him i don't know if she hit
him yeah women aren't always the best at
aiming that's okay baby steps
so that's just from the last men have
you seen the bathroom here come on guys
this is from the last couple of days
yeah and this happens millions of times
per year and you just saw a clear
example with a man who i don't know that
he would have saved his wife
not saying it would have doesn't matter
it could not be less relevant deserve
the chance well yeah it's zero percent
though if you do nothing yeah or stop so
well and i if i
i'm not mistaken one of these teachers
that died died on the way to the
hospital
i don't know for sure but yeah i read
that in some of the reports and so if
that is in fact true and i don't know
that it was this one it may have been
one of the you know the only other
teacher that was killed but if that's
true then time mattered right even if he
even if he couldn't do anything to
prevent her being shot obviously she had
been shot at that point
he could have gotten pressure on a wound
he could have dragged her out and gotten
her to a medic he could have given her a
fighting chance said last words all of
these like you you could not keep me
back like there's nothing that i
wouldn't do to get to my wife who's been
shot and called i can't imagine getting
that call yeah there would just be
nothing you could do and you know what
um
whatever it is that he could have done
could have would have shoulda would have
been more than what the cops did which
was nothing
no
thing
not something i know what some of you
are thinking right
something no
well they stood in the hallway yeah they
did looking with an aggressive posture
not really not really that aggressive
not even that they were standing like
bambi when learning how to walk they
were behind a brick wall like kind of
peering out occasionally to an empty
hallway right it was really exciting yes
is it lunch yet yeah
i wonder if the bell will ring and he'll
go out of the classroom listening to
gunfire yeah
that you clearly wasn't an automatic
weapon meaning they could have gone down
there and at least one of them could
have got him yeah
oh but it would be dangerous for
officers
then you shouldn't be an officer draw
his fire
what the hell so all right let's get to
the eval valdez i say who valedict
because i said the right hispanic ooh
valdi i don't care
an update here on a valley and i want uh
you know this is one of those things i
very rarely use the word disgusted
that's the easiest thing for pundits to
say you know these like talking like
disgusting this is disgusting
i honestly was sick to my stomach this
morning reading about this is it just me
as am i am i am into this too deep at
this point
i found myself literally nauseous this
morning when reading about this withhu
valde and what the cops did so
uh
here what do we have here this first
clip what's the next clip it's uh uh uh
colonel steve mcgraw
um he called the police chief's response
that's right he called it an abject
failure here before texas senate um
special committee hearing and then we'll
get into this is important the claims
that were made and i'll need you to
admonish me and i'll explain to you why
the claims that were made then
that everyone believed including people
in this room
versus what we know now because this
you don't need a conspiracy
to see
the ugliest side of humanity and i mean
that the ugliest most cowardly side of
humanity and yes that applies to every
police officer don't care if you wanted
to do the right thing you didn't
here's a colonel doing a bit there's
compelling evidence
that the law enforcement response to the
attack at rob elementary
was an abject failure and antithetical
to everything we've learned over the
last two decades since the columbine
massacre three minutes after the subject
entered the west building
there was sufficient number of armed
officers wearing body armor
to isolate distract and neutralize the
subject
the only thing stopping a hallway of
dedicated officers from in room 111
and 112 was the on-scene commander
who decided to place the lives of
officers before the lives of children
one hour
14 minutes and eight seconds
that's how long the children waited and
the teachers waited
in rooms 111 to be rescued
and while they waited
the on-scene commander
waited for a radio and rifles
then he waited for shields
then he waited for swat
lastly he waited for a key that was
never needed
okay
all right because i don't want to be one
of those people who's just outraged you
know like liberal oh i can't believe it
son of a [ __ ] why don't you pass gun
control no no no i'm actually really mad
because uh we know that people were
murdered
we know that people were murdered and at
least some of it
at least some of it after murder one two
three four some of them were entirely
preventable yeah i don't mean through
some
sort of uh
abstract idea of a law somewhere i mean
no there were people there with the
equipment they needed to stop a threat
to stop a murderous
psychopath from killing children and
they didn't so let's go through exactly
what that is what we were told back
then right we were told that uh the
gunman
was already inside a locked classroom by
the way really quickly admonish me
everyone here admonish everyone in the
studio we all believe that
remember
we all did sounded reasonable we all
believed that the door was locked yeah
and i remember even talking about this
thing well maybe we need to make some
kind of breaching tool uh to be standard
with police officers as opposed to
having to wait for swat we'll get to
that too because i was also wrong about
that it turned out that tool was a hand
yes hmm these are technical terms that
dave knows that we need not concern
ourselves with that's why we have him as
our technical door opening advisor
that's what i do they just needed to
pull a harry from home alone and go
or a push right light push
if only there had been a breeze
so remember chief aerodondo he claimed
that he tried dozens of keys from the
hallway and here's an actual quote each
time i tried a key i was just praying
lock him up with a key and throw it away
how about that because it's not just oh
each time i that's a lie that is a lie
that's a lie because well how do we know
here's what we know
now
it wasn't it can't lock from the inside
the classroom door was it locked or not
locked you cannot lock this door from
the inside of the classroom that's also
a problem there's nothing the teacher
could do to lock the door inside the
classroom the teacher can come outside
the classroom
as the requirement is to lock the door
with it with a key only with the key
and this right here by turning it
you know and in line the lock position
and i can actually have the door of a of
another this is this came from the west
building one of the doors right here and
i can demonstrate that if you'd like at
this time mr chairman so the teacher
could not even lock the classroom door
from the inside that's correct there's
no way to lock the door from the inside
there's no way to lock the door from the
inside
i just have to make a point really
quickly here because he's hiding behind
the fact that oh i was waiting on keys
look at the statement that we put up in
the overlay 77 minutes after this began
it went on for one hour and 14 minutes
yep right 77 minutes they finally were
able to unlock the door
trying a dozen keys the janitor from
rocking bullwinkle takes seconds by the
way so what were you doing for the other
75 76 minutes you can't hide behind the
door was locked even though we know it
couldn't possibly be locked from the end
how many minutes on average lifetime
i don't know but i hope he spends it
behind bars yeah
so uh this brings us to then what we
were told
the police doesn't didn't hesitate
right here's chief eridando not a single
responding officer ever hesitated even
for a moment to put themselves at risk
to save the children
here's what we know now
beyond any shadow of a doubt instead of
even trying to breach now i'm not saying
unsuccessfully right right right right
instead of even attempting to breach
19 officers
waited in the hallway with an unlocked
door
waiting at the command of chief
aerodondo and this is the problem
when we you know jordan peterson has
said this and we've all talked about it
when weak people get into positions of
power
that's a weak man chief ferodondo and
unfortunately because you have a you
have a chain of command people have to
follow
a weak man
unbelievable by the way also even if the
door had been locked okay here's another
thing that we know now even if the door
had been locked
they actually had you can hit the no
they had
a halogen crowbar
with them to break it open so they
didn't have that so we were told they
didn't have the tool they didn't have
the tool they didn't need the tool they
just needed to jiggle the handle yeah by
the way if they were like oh we could
have been shot through the door did you
see the guys with the big clear
plasticky things yeah those are called
ballistic shields you know what they do
right they stop or at least help you
defend yourself against somebody
shooting at you right right you could
have walked you know who didn't have the
ballistic shields
kids teachers you know who also didn't
have the ballistic shield the man they
disarmed and detained who was trying to
go in and save his wife this is also
don't underestimate this let me ask you
something really quickly because people
talk about this with go oh good guy with
a gun you're saying you're more
effective than a cop yes let me explain
to you why
do you know what your kid needs better
than you
better than a cop sorry do you know what
your kidney needs better than a cop do
you know what your kid needs better than
a teacher
hey would you say that you're more
willing to go to extremes to save your
child's life yeah
than the local crossing guard
why why aren't we
accounting for that
it's not just a good guy with a gun how
about a motivated person with a gun not
motivated by a pension
a cadillac pension with benefits so long
as they make sure to stay away from the
calamities of the world that they're
paid to serve and protect
why do we discount that hey maybe you
know what maybe i'm not great with a gun
but uh i'm willing to put myself in the
line of fire
to save my kids you're not yeah what
about this how about we put the 19
parents in that hallway whose kids were
in that classroom and let's see if they
waited from three minutes to an hour and
14 minutes to go in unarmed let's just
not even give the parents guns every one
of them would have gone into that room
to stop this with no weapons at all some
were trying to yeah
no but the good thing is the cops are
doing their job stopping them oh yeah
well i mean that was the important part
yeah doing nothing yeah by doing nothing
guarantee you i would bet my life on it
give night pick the the parents of the
19 kids meaning i'm assuming that some
of them have never shot a gun in their
life ever
give those 19 parents guns put them in
the halls that should get stopped
yeah that shooter gets stopped
well what makes me think that i think
they probably would have tried to open
the door
i think they would have been willing to
enter the door
i think quite a few of them would have
been taken out
and eventually one of them would have
gone to the shooter but you know what i
like the odds better and this is the
problem with you know i've always said
this
we all
have a worldview
and
if your worldview includes the belief
that human beings are inherently flawed
or inherently sinful or inherently
looking out for their own best interests
then you have to be a conservative
because the last thing you want to do is
centralize the power of those people at
least with a free enterprise system it's
mitigated if someone's corrupt over here
well guess what you don't have to buy
their product or service
there's at least some competition the
problem is when it's centralized
government they have a monopoly when
they have a monopoly like for example
security for example the police force
i'm not saying that we go out and make
it a private police force and have
mercenaries that's not what i'm saying
but what i am saying is hey we see when
there's corruption when there's weakness
and it's centralized there's no way to
safeguard against it
the intruders in your house the
intruders in your house
the police were there
i would actually argue they're an
accessory to murder in stopping
the father and the mothers who tried to
go in and save those kids again am i in
this too deep is it just me does that
sound too extreme i think that the cop
who stopped the man who was going in to
save his wife with a firearm
is bordering on accessory to murder
i agree
actually so
and you know what no one's acknowledged
what the problem is hey where are all
the people talking about rooting out
corruption no not defund the police i'm
not saying defund the police how about
we make police accountable
oh wait a second wait a second now we're
dealing with unions
well defining police sure isn't helping
right i mean you have people leaving the
force early you have good cops that
don't want to do it you have good people
that don't want to do it and you end up
with this there's going to be more of
this
lower wages yeah i mean this is
what's going to happen make it
performance based and by performance
based i don't mean civilian interactions
this is a big dirty secret too that no
one wants to talk about with police
some of these municipalities are based
on civilian interactions you're actually
considered a better cop if you give out
eight speeding tickets tonight than if
you stop one rapist right so how about
we change this with the police common
ground let's start with this uh we don't
need to defund anything let's just keep
the money where it is let's just let's
just say we don't touch the money right
now yeah make it performance based
get rid of the unions
and you're not a tax collector for the
state you're there to serve and protect
yeah it's a point system you know
tickets are maybe one point uh stopping
a rape is maybe a hundred yeah
you get an office party there you go
maybe a cake stop a shooting you get
some paid leave there you go
not because uh not because you beat some
old lady with a crowbar accidentally
because she was carrying a firearm and
you get paid leave as your as your
punishment we do have a problem with the
police here in this country not all
police but look just like i talked
yesterday about women
white suburban women who are now going i
can't believe a formula shortage i can't
believe it competing in men competing in
women's sports
we called out white suburban women
yesterday no it's a little hard on you
rightfully so you need to clean ranks
guess what
cops you have to do it too yeah
you have to do it now
any cop who doesn't come out now and say
this is disgusting
and we need reform of the police to make
sure that this does not happen
you're part of the problem
this is one of the few this is one of
the few areas where you could actually
argue that science equates to actual
violence
silence could occur silence when you
look at silence from all those officers
who didn't say hey
hey
maybe we should go in
people died
and you know what this sucks i know i
hate to say it i know that some of these
cops are dealing with guilt believe me
it's not lost on me you're dealing with
guilt
i pray that we don't i really do pray
that we don't see these these officers
end up committing suicide which is not
an altogether uncommon likelihood after
scenarios like this i know they're
dealing with trauma and stress but you
don't get to get off the hook man
sorry
sorry
kids died that didn't have to because
you didn't do
the one job you're assigned to do it's
not to create seat belt laws it's not to
enforce helmet laws
that's not what you're there to do
you're there to protect
the lives of the most particularly the
most helpless among us and protect our
constitutional rights so if you're not
going to protect the police aren't going
to protect the most vulnerable among us
at least allow us to do it
and instead we have a bill coming down
the pike that says less of that less of
that more centralized power to the cops
oh and to the military by the way which
includes psychopaths who would rather
discuss
myriad gender pronouns
than their actual job hey this really
comes down to maybe it could be let's
just let's just redefine job roles we do
that here in this uh yeah if i just came
on to the show today and
you just heard the theme song and i just
you see what she's doing but i don't
feel like doing my job today
it's just i don't feel like doing it but
you have one job yeah but that but i
don't want to though but
i don't want to do it so let's define
job roles
let's define job roles for teachers
let's find job roles for police officers
how about the military i think your
primary job as a police officer is to
protect and by protect what does that
mean protect citizens and by protecting
the citizens you protect their god-given
constitutional rights and to serve
hey does that go back to some christian
principle serving yeah people people who
serve the best amongst something like
that i don't know i believe it says it's
somewhere in the back hey military your
job
is to kill and break [ __ ]
your job is to make your job is not this
is the thing
maternity suits
i'm sorry
maternity suits for pregnant female
pilots gender pronouns your job in the
military is not to create a comfortable
space
for a diversity inclusion seminar your
job is to make the other guys space
pardon me as uncomfortable as [ __ ]
possible well and get used to extreme
discomfort yes from what i've heard from
everybody that's ever
served i have an idea right now yes
if if you raise your hand and you say i
am so glad we're doing the pronouns
thing or thankfully i can have somebody
immediately you are removed from the
service we do not require your services
any longer if you're putting your tag in
the email of my pronouns if you
introduce yourself hi i'm gerald he
yeah nobody's going to come back if
that's their thing sorry you know what
you should be called whatever your
sergeant feels like calling you that day
and you better pray it's not an
embarrassing nickname that sticks and
you better snap too when he calls you
that all right that's how this works i'm
sorry this is not the military that we
need do you know what nickname sticks
and this is like a common thing in
brazilian jiu jitsu whichever one you
hate the most oh yeah the one you've
pushed back on the most nobody gets
t-boned right nobody gets t-bo nobody
gets no
coco you look like coco with the green
t-bone
name that reference t-bone you can
comment below speaking of disgusting yes
uncomfortable
yes unsightly uncomfortable yes
turns out that there's a study now it
was published in the journal uh
of clinical and translational resource
and technology
i don't know insights is this is that
the name do i have that right it sounds
right okay it sounds really stupid
though
this is true yes this is science this is
100 true trust the science huh follow it
maybe not this science be silent follow
your nose
wear masks not don't do the cocoa puffs
fruit loops
poopy researchers have found in layman's
terms uh basically mammals can
potentially breathe through their
through their through their butt
through their buttholes
[Laughter]
and i didn't believe it wow
[Music]
turns out i think well i don't know i
didn't i still don't believe it so uh
interested to find out more uh we now go
to our on the ground correspondent
thomas finnegan
[Music]
hey hi stephen hey thomas hi
um you may have seen in recent news
regarding anal breathing yes what is it
anal breathing
reptiles and amphibians they have the
ability to breathe underwater
through their cloaca which acts both as
their anus and their vivo
their in their [ __ ] scientists have
done experiments with mammals by putting
them under water and oxygenating them
through the anus with a 61 increased
survival rate that just sounds like
drowning that's just 61 longer of
drowning
what are you doing right now allow me to
demonstrate i'm uh
no
is this finnegan thomas you cannot
breathe
through your ass finnegan we should let
him try can he hear me does he have a
mic
yeah
i think he can't hear you
well valiant effort
[Music]
what he'll bounce back he always does
yeah he just the butt needs to be higher
out of the water i think so yeah yeah
just not arced correctly
somebody needs to give him ass to ass
yeah
i mean i mean science
i mean what is that not why you save
someone i think that's how you save
someone yeah he was not part of the 61
that's almost like when you use one of
those toilet seats it has like the soft
cover that's what it feels like so when
you see a beautiful girl choking in the
restaurant yeah you're like i'll save
her right yeah and he was kind of
waterboarding himself with his ass
because yeah
hey by the way dave's going to be in
columbus ohio july 15th and 16th uh and
i'm going gonna be in uh is it spokane
comedy club not come we added uh yes
spokane we added a show uh uh on
thursday so yeah a6 i think it should be
spokane
but it's spokane it's spokane spokane
but spokane sounds way cooler yeah what
are we gonna what are we playing oh oh
oh okay there's no way we can play this
on because i know what we're doing today
so uh youtube rumble thank you very much
but youtube we're about to go play
hipster hobo for mug club only and you
guys look share this show if you're
watching here on youtube right now
uh another little
a little pissed off today but uh
hopefully we still made it work for you
sometimes i really need to get uh i need
to make sure that every day i come in
i'm you know even-tempered yeah
angry
is it i prefer you anything
ladies
[Laughter]
call me ed norton because i will be your
mediocre hulk
youtube piss off